Ana: Mateo, antes de abrir el libro, déjame hacer una pregunta de café: ¿por qué la historia del derecho costarricense merece contarse como si fuera una conversación viva, y no como una lista de leyes viejas?
Mateo: Porque las leyes viejas, cuando uno las mira con paciencia, no están muertas. Son como capas de una ciudad. Uno camina por San José, por Cartago, por cualquier cantón, y debajo de cada costumbre cívica hay una decisión institucional anterior: quién podía mandar, quién podía reclamar, quién tenía tierra, quién tenía voz.
Ana: Me gusta esa imagen. Y en el prólogo hay una idea fuerte: Costa Rica es pequeña, pero produjo una experiencia jurídica notable. Pasó de provincia remota del imperio español a Estado sin ejército, con derechos sociales constitucionalizados y una Sala Constitucional que cambió la relación entre ciudadano y poder.
Mateo: Y lo interesante es que el texto no quiere caer ni en himno patriótico ni en desencanto automático. No dice: somos excepcionales y perfectos. Tampoco dice: todo fue simulación. Propone mirar instituciones, leyes y corrientes de pensamiento, con sus tensiones.
Ana: La gran tensión es liberalismo y justicia social. No como pelea de buenos contra malos, sino como dos formas de entender libertad, igualdad y Estado. Esa es una conversación que Costa Rica ha tenido durante casi toda su vida republicana.
Mateo: Exacto. El liberalismo del siglo diecinueve ayudó a levantar el Estado de derecho: igualdad formal ante la ley, propiedad privada, libertad de comercio, educación pública y laica. Pero ese mismo edificio no resolvía por sí solo la desigualdad material ni la protección del trabajador.
Ana: Y ahí entra el reformismo social de los años cuarenta: garantías sociales, Código de Trabajo, seguro social, salario mínimo, jornada máxima. No destruye el edificio liberal; le agrega otro piso. Ese matiz es precioso.
Mateo: Es una síntesis conflictiva. La Constitución de 1949 conserva propiedad privada y libertad de empresa, pero junto a derecho al trabajo, función social de la propiedad y protección especial de familia, madre, niño, anciano y trabajador. Costa Rica no escoge una sola palabra; aprende a vivir entre varias.
Ana: Antes de entrar al período colonial, también hay que hablar del método. Este podcast viene de un corpus digital jurídico, no de una investigación en archivos físicos. Eso obliga a ser honestos: hay hechos documentados, hechos pendientes de verificación e interpretaciones.
Mateo: Esa honestidad metodológica importa mucho. En derecho, sonar seguro es fácil. Ser verificable es más difícil. El material advierte que muchas fechas históricas o datos institucionales requieren contraste con fuentes primarias, especialmente por limitaciones de acceso a sitios oficiales durante la elaboración.
Ana: Entonces, el primer acto no es decir: aquí está la verdad definitiva. Es decir: aquí está una lectura institucional clara, basada en corpus legal y conocimiento histórico consolidado, con sus límites a la vista.
Mateo: Y ahora sí, volvamos al origen colonial. La escena inicial es casi antiépica: Costa Rica no nace como centro del poder imperial. Colón toca la zona de Limón en 1502, pero la colonización efectiva del Valle Central llega mucho después, hacia la década de 1560.
Ana: Esa marginalidad va a importar. Costa Rica formaba parte de la Capitanía General de Guatemala, dentro del Virreinato de la Nueva España. Era provincia austral, pobre, lejos de los centros administrativos y comerciales.
Mateo: Y a diferencia de otros lugares de América, no tenía grandes concentraciones de población indígena sometida ni minas inmensas. La encomienda fue débil y de corta duración. Eso no convierte a la colonia en un paraíso igualitario, pero sí crea una estructura social distinta.
Ana: El texto insiste en evitar la postal idílica. Había pobreza, jerarquías raciales, conflictos por tierras, tensiones entre Cartago y San José. Pero también predominaban pequeños y medianos propietarios, con una élite criolla más modesta que la de otros centros regionales.
Mateo: En ese suelo social opera el Derecho Indiano. Y aquí conviene detenernos: no era un código único y ordenado como podría imaginar un estudiante moderno. Era un sistema plural: Leyes de Indias, cédulas reales, ordenanzas, costumbre local y Derecho Castellano supletorio.
Ana: O sea, una especie de biblioteca jurídica imperial, pero usada a distancia, con comunicaciones lentas y aplicación irregular.
Mateo: Justamente. El Derecho Indiano era casuístico: muchas normas nacían para resolver casos concretos. También era formalmente centralista, porque el rey legislaba desde Madrid, pero en la práctica la distancia abría un espacio enorme entre obedecer la norma y cumplirla.
Ana: Esa frase colonial, se acata pero no se cumple, es fascinante. No significa simple rebeldía. Es más bien una técnica política: reconozco la autoridad, pero suspendo la eficacia porque la realidad local no cabe en la orden recibida.
Mateo: Y ese divorcio entre norma escrita y aplicación efectiva deja una huella. En Costa Rica posterior veremos muchas veces la pregunta: ¿tenemos instituciones fuertes porque la ley lo dice, o porque existe una práctica social que la sostiene?
Ana: Hablemos de instituciones coloniales. El gobernador reunía funciones administrativas, militares y judiciales. La Real Audiencia de Guatemala era tribunal superior. Pero para mucha gente, Guatemala quedaba demasiado lejos como para ser justicia cotidiana.
Mateo: Por eso los cabildos fueron tan importantes. Eran ayuntamientos locales: regulaban comercio, precios de alimentos, tierras comunales, y funcionaban como espacio de participación de la élite criolla. En Cartago, San José, Heredia y Alajuela, el cabildo era una escuela temprana de vida política.
Ana: Y más adelante, los cabildos abiertos serían una puerta institucional para expresar la independencia. No una revolución abstracta en el aire, sino una decisión pronunciada desde una forma jurídica heredada.
Mateo: También está la Iglesia, con el Patronato Regio y el fuero eclesiástico. La Corona y la Iglesia estaban entrelazadas. El monarca presentaba candidatos a cargos eclesiásticos y recaudaba diezmo; la Iglesia tenía jurisdicción sobre clérigos y ciertas materias de familia y matrimonio.
Ana: Esa dualidad civil y eclesiástica va a sobrevivir al período colonial como tema de conflicto. Cuando el liberalismo del siglo diecinueve impulse secularización y educación laica, no estará peleando contra una sombra, sino contra una arquitectura institucional real.
Mateo: En economía, el retrato también es sobrio: cacao en Matina, tabaco como estanco real desde el siglo dieciocho, agricultura de subsistencia, ganadería menor. Una colonia pobre, con poca acumulación comparada con otros territorios.
Ana: Pero esa pobreza relativa también modula el derecho. Donde no hay gran aparato estatal ni riqueza minera, el derecho no se vive como maquinaria imperial perfecta. Se vive como arreglo local, costumbre, cabildo, trámite difícil, autoridad lejana.
Mateo: Por eso el legado del Derecho Indiano no es solo un conjunto de normas. Es una forma de pensar el derecho: tradición romanista, importancia de la ley escrita, peso de la costumbre, pluralidad de fuentes, casuismo y una brecha persistente entre norma y aplicación.
Ana: Me parece que ahí aparece la primera clave de toda la serie: Costa Rica no hereda instituciones limpias, sino tensiones. La ley quiere ordenar; la realidad local la adapta. El Estado quiere centralizar; el territorio lo obliga a negociar. La religión organiza la vida social; el liberalismo luego intenta separar esferas.
Mateo: Y más adelante, cuando lleguen independencia, café, liberalismo, reforma social y Constitución de 1949, esas tensiones no desaparecen. Se transforman. La historia jurídica de Costa Rica es menos una línea recta y más una conversación larga entre orden, libertad, propiedad, comunidad y justicia.
Ana: Entonces cerremos esta primera taza con una idea: la historia del derecho costarricense empieza en una provincia marginal, bajo un derecho imperial plural y distante. Pero justamente ahí se forman hábitos locales que después serán políticos: cabildo, pequeña propiedad, negociación, costumbre y una relación pragmática con la ley.
Mateo: Y la pregunta queda servida para la siguiente parte: cuando la independencia llegue, ¿Costa Rica inventará un país desde cero, o reorganizará jurídicamente lo que ya venía practicando en silencio?
Ana: Esa pregunta merece otro café.